this time
someone's head is underwater clock's
immediately ticking
he was gone
don't move don't move i hope he's not
dead by the time we get one back up
there back up
we need help
this volcanic island is in the indian
ocean off the coast of madagascar
champion writer cedric garcia along with
friends pascal minuet and jerome caffey
make the pilgrimage to take part in the
island's world famous downhill mountain
bike race
the megavalanche
this is a big event i mean if you want
to rein an island meets like you really
complete as an athlete
all-terrain course
is breathtaking
and treacherous
the start is really scary because it's
just like the kind of rocks and if you
crash there it's really
those rocks are not friendly
it kind of gets dangerous because it's
always kind of wet in the woods
it's difficult but
it's fun as well
[Music]
morning practice five days before the
race
cedric and his friends prepare to run
through the course
because we there for one week the first
couple days you know i just ride with
them and hang out
cedric in the yellow and orange sports
an action camera to film the run
next to him in white and green is jerome
pascal in the glasses is also recording
with a helmet cam
[Music]
is normal
and we ride we ride
a real easy trap
and i just follow surrey
i always lead if i want to go fast i
will just go on the front and take off
[Music]
six miles from the nearest town the
trail enters the sugar cane field
[Music]
despite the muddy terrain
cedric continues to set an intense pace
when suddenly
i just lost the front just starts
sliding
i usually hold on to my handlebar
and it just
i hit a rock on the ground i'm sliding
on the ground
it went straight in into my bone
and it hurt pretty much
we don't understand what happened in
this moment
and i stopped immediately i screamed you
are good
what happened
to
at this moment we realized there is a
terrible problem
[Music]
in the freak fall
cedric's handlebars break off
part of his bike slices his groin
lacerating the femoral artery
which pumps nearly two pints of blood
per minute to his leg
the gash is too high for a tourniquet if
they can't stem the blood flow cedric
will die within 15 minutes
i never
see
anybody looking like
my team
it's really
impressive you know
plowed every everywhere in one second
there was so much blood i told the guy
it smelled like death
you see the fear of the people big fears
like on the eyes
i was really scared we don't know how to
fix this
pascal tries to apply pressure
but it doesn't stop the bleeding
foreign
it's difficult and i try to say him
it's good
we are
in the good way but
i don't know it's uh
if it's true
three minutes after the accident
cedric's already lost around 20 of his
blood if he loses more than half
his body will go into shock and start
shutting down
we lose too much blood
my body was telling me
you're going to die
i realize you have to fix it
fix it quick
but we don't know what we're doing
already
we try to listen uh instinct
i just try to open up my leg i put my
hand in
and try to find i guess the vein or
something to try to put it into the bone
to stop the bleeding
[Music]
incredibly cedric manages to press the
femoral artery directly against his
thigh bone
it slows but doesn't stop the blood loss
it's a real situation
i knew it's only
a little chance we make it
four minutes since the accident
reducing the loss of blood gives them
more time without urgent medical help
cedric's fate is only being delayed
jerome is on the phone
to emergency services
you try to explain you need a helicopter
and i said no no no
don't worry it's not a problem we will
call firemen they will arrive
the first responders will be fire
service medics standard practice for the
bike accidents common on the island
they're used to dealing with broken
bones
but this
is life or death
they said
it's not a big problem
yes it is a big problem
mountain bike champion cedric garcia has
sliced his femoral artery in a freak
accident
and is bleeding to death
cedric forces his fingers inside his
room to hold the artery closed
it slows
but doesn't stop the bleeding
without medical attention he will
eight minutes after the accident
an ambulance is dispatched but cedric is
injured in the middle of a sugarcane
field
it will take the ambulance team at least
20 minutes to reach him
the drive to the hospital
is another hour
no no no no no no no
no no
no
it's now 20 minutes since the accident
[Music]
the agonizing weight goes on
cedric continues to lose precious blood
[Music]
the fire service medics arrived
[Music]
[Music]
they saw the blood everywhere
cedric has now lost nearly half his
blood he's entering a life-threatening
stage where at any second his heart
could stop beating
cedric's only chance of survival is a
blood transfusion but the medics don't
carry any blood
and then they helped us because
they
took the phone and called oh it's a big
problem it's not for us you must call a
helicopter
finally cedric catches a break by chance
a rescue helicopter is already in the
air
when the call
came i was
in a helicopter with a medical doctor
each month we've got a training with a
mountain rescuer and i was in the
helicopter for a special training
so we win time
they head towards the scene not stopping
for blood so they can get to their
patient as quickly as possible
but they're still 10 minutes away
if cedric loses consciousness
he could slip into a coma and never wake
up
it is now 40 minutes since the crash
i perfectly remember
the few words he said i don't
want to die
that was absolutely clear
that's a little pressure
and adrenaline to increase his
dangerously low heart rate
he said
[Music]
[Music]
helicopter was a critical moment
[Music]
four people have to push cedric up and
carry him to the helicopter
and one have to push down through the
motion to stop the bleeding and it's
very difficult
[Music]
i asked everybody even if we were really
tired
to be
readily concentrated
cedric is still losing blood
at any moment his heart could stop
when i leave him in the helicopter he's
alone now
to the finish
cedric's chances of survival are less
than 50 percent
on reunion island cedric garcia is
bleeding to death
40 minutes ago he severed his femoral
artery
he's lost half his blood a rescue
helicopter lifts him to the emergency
care and the blood transfusion he needs
to survive
at the hospital
cedric has a blood transfusion an
emergency surgery on his artery
in my career i see perhaps two or three
artery cuts
and
cedric was the only one who survived
[Music]
in two or three minutes more he was dead
that's absolutely sure
incredible
thanks to the quick action of his
friends and all the medical staff
cedric walked out of the hospital two
days later
and was soon back competing on his bike
what's he really do it's very difficult
a normal person like me it's impossible
three years after his near-death
experience
cedric completes his comeback
making the podium on reunion for the
third time
we went through something like not many
people went through
and i think our fight as well
to please
my friend
more than i fight for me to survive
i think now we rise even more like it
doesn't matter what happened we always
be there
[Music]
the chioa is normally a lazy river
except
when the floodgates open
20 times a year this antiqua dam
releases
more than 7 thousand gallons of water
thunders downstream every second
[Music]
transforming the chioa river into a
white water mecca
that attracts extreme kayakers from all
over the country
[Music]
yeah you were too far left and got
sideways as you came down and just broke
stopped
kyle kinney caroline coleman and josh
gaffney make the 12-hour trip to
philadelphia to take on the rapids
whenever they can
i usually paddle with josh and caroline
[Music]
caroline's a very experienced kayaker
she's been doing it longer than i have
i love paddling with her
greatly
since the dam releases began in 2005 the
extreme rapids have claimed the lives of
three experienced paddlers
it's really important that you do have
people that you trust because as much as
nobody plans on anything going wrong
there's always the risk that something
will happen
kyle is wearing a waterproof camera to
film the action
the weather was really perfect for
kayaking it was just
plenty of water coming out of the dam
blue skies great spring deck
30 minutes into the rug the rapid right
in front of the poco lodge it's a little
bit on the easier side
and you know coming into it we're
feeling great
i entered the rapid i choose to go on
the left side it was a little bit more
technical than going down the right side
of the river
i pull into an eddy which is slow moving
water to make sure the people behind me
are right
her head was under the water she was
upside down and that's about as bad a
spot as you can be
that's a deadly situation
caroline is trapped in the tree 80 feet
upstream from kyle
her body is tangled in the branches
making it impossible to escape
without help she could drown within 60
seconds
[Music]
if someone's head is underwater clock's
immediately ticking
there's no way to navigate the water
back upstream
i ferried across the water to the
opposite side
it is now 70 seconds since caroline
capsized
she needs to be rescued immediately
i was thinking you know
how am i gonna get out there to her
i
think you want to hook me up
you want to go in
yeah
i'm now going upstream
so that way i could float down to here
caroline has been fighting for her life
for two minutes
anytime you're jumping into a river
you are putting yourself in danger
i had adrenaline going
i needed to get myself to focus
it was go time
carolyn coleman is trapped in a tree in
chioa river rapids
she's been fighting for breath
for over two minutes
any second she could drown
her friend kyle
is her only hope
here i go
this is
when i got up to her i noticed her head
was above water
which was a huge sigh of relief
she can breathe but she's not out of
danger yet
okay
you can see it okay
after i got to her and realized she's
with it
talking to me
then it is uh looking for a plan of
evacuation getting her off that tree
right you
gotta put you on the other side of the
branch
okay
you just have to take that second to
make sure that you're you're calm and
you're thinking straight and that you're
not gonna make anything worse
find your back
you're gonna go on behind on the
upstream side of this branch
okay
move your arm
you're gonna contribute to the other
side
okay
ready
any wrong move and the force of 30 tons
of water rushing past every second could
force caroline back under
all right you
you're right
four minutes into the rescue
she looked very tired
she looked in pain from the pressure of
the water just putting so much force on
her body and her boat so
it was we got to get her out
behind caroline are submerged rocks
kyle decides his best option is to push
her around him to the safer right-hand
side of the river
[Music]
[Music]
upside down
you don't want to go that way
yeah but i'm going to be able to push
you around the back side of me behind
you
you want to go that way or you want to
feed or cut on this back
other members of our group they were
thinking in terms of lines of defense
kyle's up first
if caroline washes to my side of the
river i'll be in a position to help
rescue her she washes all the way down
into the pool we've got a third line of
defense people ready to take action
with everybody in position
it's now
or never
get one shot
he's gonna go around
i got you
[Music]
i end up
turning her boat which makes her capsize
i start to worry she's still in danger
she was upside down i don't know how
much strength she had left
everyone holds their breath
[Music]
on the raging chioa river kayaker
caroline coleman has been pinned to a
tree
fighting for breath for over seven
minutes
before friend kyle
finally releases her
in trying to aim or steer her down the
rest of the rapid
i end up
turning her boat which makes her go
upside down
caroline's back
in mortal danger
underwater her head could be crashing
against rocks
a hundred feet downstream
out of sight of kyle's camera
caroline emerges out of the water
[Music]
i was exhausted
somebody grabbed the boat got me to
shore
and i i was uh
safe on land again
it was like okay i'll live the paddle
another day
[Music]
caroline's safe
but now
kyle is the one trapped
i need to get out of here safely
i don't want to be the next person to be
rescued
the only way back to shore is through
churning white water
littered with rocks
if he's misjudges jump you can get
washed into those rocks foot entrapment
risk is always there
i got the rope
and the tension
swung me to the shore
and by the time i got out of the water
it was kind of a high five moment like
hey we did it
thank you
i kayaked that same river the next day
i wanted to get back on the horse
the group of friends that i paddle with
we look out for each other
we care about each other we got each
other's back
for sure kai was the biggest hero
what he did was pretty cool
[Music]
lee dabal
his wife briar come on bro
and friends are on their annual ski trip
exploring the untracked terrain of the
chilketon mountains
where are we what are we doing
at the top of what i think is
chipmunk peak but uh i don't see a lot
of chipmunks a lot of peaks though a lot
of peaks in the background chuckleton
mountain range
as far as you can see
above the clouds there
we have fun in the back country it's
adventurous lee has been instrumental in
pushing me to my ski limits i guess yeah
for sure
traveling by snow cap the group tackles
some of the remotest peaks in this 15
000 acre playground
filming everything on helmet cans
you're in an environment that isn't
controlled
you can't
assume that you're safe
i can call 9-1-1 and maybe if myself
working the police will be there in two
and a half hours
within our pack we have ski probe
we have a shovel
we all have avalanche beacons on
oh sweet
[Music]
i turn on my my helmet cam
you know we all group up the guide tells
us about the run
uh particular hazards that may be on the
run where we might need to go so where
is that exactly we're just gonna roll
straight and just slide down briar's
tracks here she'll be set up there
somewhere
todd's helmet cam records breyer
and lee beginning their run
[Music]
all of a sudden i just saw this cloud of
snow
he was gone
within seconds
out of my sight that's how fast it
happens
todd's camera captures the moment lee
disappears
[Music]
i saw the tracks going towards the tree
so i didn't know if he had run into it
or had fallen into it
he was in trouble you know he was in
deep trouble
yeah
hey hold don't move don't move don't
move don't don't move
don't move
it wasn't until i got closer that i
realized what had actually happened
hold up don't move
it's just very
shocking to see him completely submerged
in that tree well
we got you we got you okay don't move
lee has fallen head first into a tree
well a pocket of unstable snow that
develops when branches prevent powder
from compacting around a tree trunk
without help lee could run out of oxygen
within 10 minutes a phenomenon known as
snow immersion suffocation
we're going to need help to think about
i need somebody to get my shovel out i
got i got right here
if he's injured himself in the fall he
could have even less time
he was not responding
my initial thought was what if he's
unconscious what if he's had a head
injury plea don't move
if lee has suffered severe head trauma
there's a possibility he could have
already stopped breathing
get my shovel off my pack
two minutes since the crash
skis
get my shovel off my back
he's screaming so he's breathing
at that point in time i knew that he
wasn't dead he was alive
but whatever air lee has
won't last long
you're digging as hard and as fast as
you can in that soft snow
i don't want to default
we didn't know if
there was something holding him up or if
he was just going to disappear in front
of us
the thought is i hope he's not dead by
the time we get to him
we need help
in british columbia
backcountry skier lee dabal
has fallen headlong into a tree well
he's screaming so he's breathing
his friends race to dig him out
before it becomes his tomb
[Music]
there's around 12 feet of loose snow
below lee's head acting like quicksand
one slip and he could fall deeper one
mistake from his rescuers and they could
cause a mini avalanche that will fill
any remaining air pocket he has i don't
want him to fall any deeper
hold on
no i just got a spoon
i don't think we can pull them
[Music]
[Music]
take his boot
get this ski out of here
three minutes
any small air pocket lee is surviving on
starts to run out
and in his inverted position
blood is pooling in lee's head
[Music]
if he's blacked out the clock starts to
tick
um you know that just adds to the
urgency of of what you need to do to get
him out of there as quickly as possible
we don't really know you know how long
we have
hey don't worry start looking down
straight
we gotta get them down deep
there you go
guys can you help clean the snow for
more
let me get my pack off somebody take
over shoveling it was a feeling of dread
it's not going fast enough it's not
going fast enough
[Music]
where's my shuttle handle head
hold it off my pack
there goes one of our shovels it's a
frustrating thing but what can you do
you know you make do with what you have
and you just keep focused on the goal
help andy yeah
four minutes since the fall
todd was yelling to him he's got you but
he would kick his feet and to me it
looked like someone suffocated
at this point we have to try to pull
them out because we don't have more time
[Music]
yeah watch his leg
don't worry about his legs
[Music]
okay one two three
[Music]
[Music]
after five minutes of terror
lee is free
let go of your pole here you're all
right
roll it roll this way
i was absolutely light-headed when i
came out
and sense of relief
i knew within five seconds of being in
the hall that i was unable to move
everything goes through your mind in
terms of i hope my group didn't ski past
me
or i hope somebody saw me go into this
hole we got you we got you okay don't
move
we need help we're gonna need help to
think about
from the time i went into the hall until
the time that
todd touched my boot was very short
and i cannot emphasize how
much of an eternity i thought that was
how do you tell somebody that you owe
your life to them
because there's no question that
i owe my life to my friends
had they not been there i would not be
giving this interview
[Music]
epic
happy
[Music]
you